ma mère m'a donné de très bons conseils il y a
longtemps, elle a dit euh le
bonheur est un cadeau que vous vous offrez
tous les jours
un cadeau que vous vous offrez le bonheur
et vous avez le choix de
ressentir tout ce qui
se passe dans votre vie
et vous devez soit choisir de  trouver une
façon positive de voir les choses ou une
façon négative de voir les choses
et
cela a vraiment
complètement défini ma vie
j'essaie toujours
de trouver le bien même quand les choses
sont folles
et
choisir le bonheur
est
[Musique]
euh
étranger
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
wow
wow wow wow
la famo do tutas vlog
[Musique] [
Musique] d'accord je
connais toutes mes répliques est-ce que
je fais d'accord nous verrons que c'est
inversé heidi
où allons-nous
oh tu as dit que tu avais oublié ta vie
toi